y dejan atrás un país en guerra estos
ucranianos se ven obligados a huir ante
el avance de los rusos y en la ciudad
polaca de córdoba en la frontera con
ucrania el presidente polaco se reúne
con ellos polonia acoge a más de la
mitad de los ucranianos desplazados por
la guerra gestora siento y es que hoy me
gustaría agradecer a mis compatriotas
por mostrar tanta empatía y generosidad
sobre jordi terés y llevar calidez a la
gente necesitada cuyos hogares son
destruidos por los agresores rusos
históricamente jason booth owners
agresor brosinski en eslovaquia rumanía
o aquí en hungría más de 1.2 millones de
ucranianos ya han huido de su país
[Música]
mi ciudad ha sido destruida
completamente mis amigos y mi familia no
pueden huir me siento aliviada de estar
aquí
y la inmensa mayoría de los refugiados
ucranianos son mujeres y niños a la
mayor parte de los hombres se le ha
dicho que se queden a defender su país
para los que permanecen en ucrania
además de la guerra hay otro peligro la
hambruna
rogamos a los rusos ya todas las partes
en este conflicto que nos den acceso a
la gente necesitada de lo contrario la
gente morirá de hambre muchas ciudades
asediadas ya sufren una dramática
escases de alimentos y medicinas una
crisis que según el programa mundial de
alimentos podría acarrear a una hambruna
a nivel mundial